>>> ON THURSDAY, SECRETARY OF
STATE BLINKEN ANNOUNCED
SANCTIONS AGAINST IRAN'S
MINISTERS OF THE INTERIOR AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND FIVE OTHER
OFFICIALS OF THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC.
ALL FOR THEIR ROLES IN THE
CRACKDOWN AGAINST PROTESTORS.
THE UNREST WAS SPARKED BY THE
DEATH OF A 22-YEAR-OLD WOMAN
WHO HAD BEEN ARRESTED BY THE
MORALITY POLICE, ACCUSED OF
VIOLATING IRAN'S DRESS CODE.
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE PROTESTS
AGAINST HER KILLING ARE WOMEN
AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
I WANT TO BRING IN MY NEXT GUEST
TO UNDERSTAND ITS MOVEMENT, THE
MEANING AND POWER.
SHE IS AN IRANIAN-AMERICAN
WRITER.
WELCOME.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU FIRST, WHAT
WAS YOUR -- WHAT ARE YOUR
IMPRESSIONS JUST WATCHING THESE
PROTESTS?
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU ARE
NOTICING?
>> UMM, I'M NOTICING SOMETHING I
HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE 1979.
SOME OF THE IMAGES THAT ARE
COMING OUT OF IRAN ARE VERY MUCH
REMINISCENT OF THE COUNTRY THAT
I REMEMBER, THE TURMOIL THAT I
REMEMBER FROM 1978 AND 1979.
KIDS WERE GROUPING UP.
KIDS WERE RIPPING UP THE IMAGES
OF THE SHAH OUT OF THEIR
TEXTBOOKSES
THEY WERE TEARING DOWN THE
IMAGES OF THE SUPREME LEADER
THIS TIME AROUND FROM THEIR
CLASSROOMS.
THERE IS A UNIFIED MOVEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THAT IS
FOCUSED ON A SINGULAR SLOGAN WE
HAVE NEVER HEARD, WHICH IS
"WOMEN LIKE FREEDOM" AND I THINK
IT SIGNALS TOWARD A MAJOR, MAJOR
SHIFT, FROM ALL THE PAST
DEMONSTRATIONS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN.
>> WHAT I NOTICED IS THEY WERE
TEARING PICTURES OF NOT JUST THE
CURRENT SUPREME LEADER, BUT THE
FOUNDING SUPREME LEADER OF IRAN,
WHICH STRIKES ME OF ALMOST
GETTING TO THE CORE OF THE
REGIME'S LEGITIMACY.
>> PRECISELY.
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
NO DEMONSTRATION IN THE PAST, NO
PROTEST, NO GROUP THAT HAS COME
OUT TO OBJECT TO THE REGIME, HAD
EVER GONE THIS FAR.
AND THIS MOMENT, WHERE THEY ARE
SAYING NOT ONLY THE PRESIDENT,
NOT ONLY THE CURRENT SUPREME
LEADER, BUT THE VERY FOUNDER OF
THIS REGIME IS THE VERY PERSON
THAT WE NO LONGER WANT TO
IDENTIFY WITH.
I THINK THAT IS THE SIGNAL THAT
WE HAVE REACHED A POINT OF NO
RETURN.
THAT THE NATION HAS CROSSED A
BOUNDARY THAT IT HAD NEVER
CROSSED BEFORE.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK HER CASE
TRIGGERED THIS?
>> BECAUSE SHE'S EVERY WOMAN.
BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL, SHE WAS A
KURDISH WOMAN.
SHE WAS IN TEHRAN WITH HER
BROTHER FOR A VISIT.
SHE WAS NOT AN ACTIVIST.
SHE WAS NOT IN ANY WAY, SHAPE,
OR FORM POLITICAL.
AND THE FACT THAT SHE WAS EVERY
WOMAN, THE FACT THAT SHE WAS
ORDINARY, IS THE REASON WHY
EVERYBODY IS, I THINK, SO UP IN
ARMS, BECAUSE SHE COULD BE ME,
SHE COULD BE ANYBODY'S SISTER,
ANYBODY'S MOTHER.
AND IF THAT HAPPENED TO HER,
THEN NO WOMAN IN IRAN COULD BE
SAFE.
>> I THINK I READ SOMEWHERE THAT
YOU WROTE IRANIANS HAVE TRIED
PROTESTING AND ASKING FOR REFORM
IN SO MANY WAYS.
THERE WAS THE GREEN MOVEMENT,
THAT ELECTED A WOMAN PRESIDENT
TWICE, AND NOTHING SEEMS TO
WORK.
IS THIS -- DO YOU THINK IT'S
FAIR
TO SAY THIS IS NOW AT LEAST
THESE IRANIANS ARE CALLING NOT
FOR REFORM BUT REVOLUTION?
>> THIS IS WAY PAST REFORM.
PEOPLE GAVE REFORM A LOT OF TIME
TO WORK AND IT DIDN'T.
SO THEY HAVE TURNED TO
REVOLUTION, AND THAT'S PRECISELY
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN IRAN AT THE
MOMENT.
>> IN THE PAST, THESE PROTESTS
HAVE NOT LED TO ANYTHING.
CAN THEY SUCCEED THIS TIME?
>> THE DEMONSTRATORS ARE SAYING
THEY DON'T INTEND TO GO HOME AND
THEY DON'T INTEND TO STOP.
THE REGIME, THE SYSTEM HAS
ENTIRELY LOST ITS LEGITIMACY.
WHETHER THE DEMONSTRATORS
SUCCEED OR NOT WILL DEPEND ON
THE SUPPORT THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AND THE
UNITED STATES WILL PROVIDE THEM.
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE EVERY
INCENTIVE, ESPECIALLY AMERICA,
TO DO JUST THAT.
FOR 40 PLUS YEARS, THE UNITED
STATES HAS BEEN WAITING FOR
IRANIANS TO STOP BURNING
AMERICAN FLAGS, BURNING U.S.
EFFICIENT -- EFFIGIES OF UNCLE
SAM AND NOT CONSIDERING, NOT
CALLING THE UNITED STATES THE
GREAT SATAN.
THESE DEMONSTRATORS ARE OUT ON
THE STREETS CHANTING "OUR ENEMY
IS RIGHT HERE, THEY LIE WHEN
THEY SAY IT'S THE UNITED
STATES."
WE HAVE REACHED A POINT THAT WE
HAVE ALWAYS WANTED TO REACH AS
MILES AN HOUR.
AMERICANS.
IRANIANS HAVE FORGONE THE
HOSTILITY THAT THEY HAVE HAD
WITH US.
NOW WILL WE HEAR THE VOICE OF
THE PEOPLE AS AMERICANS.
WILL WE SIDE WITH THE PEOPLE AND
DO THE RIGHT THING TO CORRECT
OUR PAST MISTAKES AS AMERICANS
IN IRAN AND OTHER PLACES IN THE
MIDDLE EAST WHERE WE SIDE WITH
THE TIE TYRANTS, AND DO WE HEAR
THE PEOPLE.
IF WE DO THAT AND RIGHT THE
THINGS WE HAVE DONE WRONG, THEN
THE DEMONSTRATORS WILL HAVE A
SHOT ACCOMPLISHING WHAT THEY
HA